the Joe Rogan experience it was the
Steven Seagal run there's a couple p.m.
I see him run and he runs very strange
in what's very tall what's the first one
he did that's really good one of the law
look at him look at how he he runs like
a [ __ ] [ __ ] look at him look can
you imagine he's just built odd he's
just really tall he does run a little
loose with the hands which is kind of
confusing which one was this one this
that's exactly that's above the law it's
cut nuts cut no oh it's all it's a bunch
of different movies now because now he's
got more hair like this people goof on
them because of the way he runs yeah he
was married to Kelly LeBrock
dog at one time dude at one time he was
the man how many times I jerk off to
Kelly LeBrock and woman and read one of
Gene Wilder calls to her he this is what
it is his steps are too short and his
wrists flip around because he's used to
do in Aikido
right like going please don't protect
them with don't throw you know in there
those Japanese people work 3,000 years
to put Aikido on the map and now you're
gonna set the back that / Aikido school
and Burbank has moved eight times they
keep losing students it down to two
students wearing a smock and a [ __ ]
sword who's gonna go for Aikido as
someone who doesn't really want to fight
and you want to you want to be able to
passively get someone away from you
which is not realistic but the sword
part the sword part could come up if
[ __ ] hits the fan if we go back and you
know if we get knocked into the Stone
Age nuclear war with Russia oh my
goodness it beat now and they joined
again no sticks then they moved their
bird back and I've thought about when I
was a kid I went to Aikido for about two
weeks it's probably fun the guy's name
was Richard ball he was I supposed to be
a big time and Guttenberg New Jersey
mm-hmm and he taught that deflection
stuff but Steven Seagal and above the
law took it to a different level that
out that a harm that throat slam oh yeah
he's got the deflection throat slam
that's [ __ ] beer
I had a meeting with a guy in a in a
movie there's this like my agent sent me
in to meet with this guy they were
looking for someone to do like a Steven
Seagal type movie they were looking to
they were gonna try to create an action
star and we actually had like a argument
about this movie that move right there
but the less places throw away the law
and the one when he [ __ ] up the
Jamaicans
oh yeah which one was that with swords
then sword fighting and hard to kill was
when he that that's the one that pissed
me off as well oh you're in a coma for
four years into these two days later
you're throwing a sidekick yeah and he's
putting like Jesus Christ Jesus Christ
you know I loved it I loved to do I
loved in - I like the thing about him
man is I think in that first movie it
was one of the more unique martial arts
movies like above the law like it's
almost a shame that he made a bunch of
movies that weren't as good because if
you go back to above the law in terms of
like martial arts history and above the
law is a legitimate historical movie in
terms of martial arts movies because it
was the first movie where you got to see
a real Aikido practitioner with a
hybridized system of martial arts like
he was doing our Kido but he was also
throwing a lot of punches and knife hand
strikes and a lot of strikes
it wasn't a showed the bodega feed and
above the law just split play this out
that's the bet all y'alls this guy look
at all the [ __ ] I mean I've made fun
of him as much as anybody but listen his
Aikido skills were very legit
he was very legit whether or not that
stuff's real or not that's a subject for
debate whether or not it's really
effective when you look at other things
like wrestling and jiu-jitsu is it the
most effective way to go out or judo is
the most effective way no it's not but
no one knew that back then
he at the time in the 1980s and 90s was
a world-class martial artist he just had
a style that ultimately didn't really
prove to be the best style but so did I
how he's doing this is this is hard to
kill a lot of people were doing kung fu
a lot of people were doing things that
they thought were legit but they really
once the UFC came around we found out oh
this is not the best way to do it now
this is 87 that's a kid in this scene
that was just in a movie with Clint
Eastwood Emile he's been doing movies
for [ __ ] 30 years I can't right now
that dude with the tattoos how many
[ __ ] movies has he's been a bad guy
in right there the second guy that guys
in every [ __ ] bad gun everything's
great quiz he what's his name he used to
live in Vegas I heard he had some a
restaurant inve I'm not even sure
[Applause]